Jennifer Lopez and Shakira took us to
church with their electric performance
at the 2020 Superbowl halftime show but
the moments filling mean of the night
went to Shakira's tongue wag the hips
don't lie singer turned to the camera
and blessed us with the first meme of
Super Bowl 50 for one Instagram post
said thanks to Shakira for my new wake
up alarm and this one with me looking at
all the Super Bowl snacks my grandma
made but fans were quick to clarify
exactly what Shakira was doing in that
moment saying that the Colombian beauty
was actually performing a vocal sound
used in popular Arab tradition called
Zagar ruta which is used to express joy
at celebrations that's right the 43 year
old performer who is part Lebanese
slayed her performance and showcased the
celebratory vocal expression on
America's biggest stage all things
considered Shakira has a lot to
celebrate she tweeted that the Superbowl
halftime show was the best birthday gift
saying quote we left he knows climbed
Kilimanjaro and made history tonight and
we couldn't have done it without all of
you during a press conference ahead of
the big performance
Shakira opened up about how she and JLo
have combined what they individually
bring to the table to put together a
great show the show and my show feel
very different but very complimentary
they complement each other I think that
we've been working so hard the past
weeks to make sure that everything is as
good as good as we can feel it that it
is
so everybody can enjoy this Sunday enjoy
a great show she also spoke about how
honored she is to represent the Latin
community and her hope to inspire those
watching when I was living in about a
media my hometown and the little girl
no one would have thought that I would
end up performing at the Super Bowl one
day it would be something hard to
believe right and it's a reality today
now and I just think that this is a
palpable example of how anything is
possible
really and the only thing that matters
is the size of your dreams I think that
we are the Latinos are going through a
difficult time in the US right now and I
think it's very important for us to
convey a message of unity and also to
show what a relevant force the Latin
community is in this country
[Music]